sé que tan fundada es la preocupación no
por una eventual invasión rusa a ucrania
pero hay muy buen fundada y según la
inteligencia de los eeuu y naturalmente
por lo que los rusos están haciendo
podría ser una invasión las tropas
podrían cruzar a grandes de crimea la
frontera rusa y a través de bielorrusia
con alrededor de digamos hay 100 grupos
tácticos de batallones potencialmente
alrededor de 100.000 soldados
desplegando los para que para una
operación en un terreno muy áspero en
condiciones naturalmente
de invierno de congelación
conquistando un extenso territorio según
los
el gobierno de ucrania ya hay más de 100
mil tropas rusas desplegada alrededor de
la frontera entre rusia y ucrania
bueno y porque entre tanto profesor la
inquietud de rusia ante los avances de
la otan hacia el este
claro esto es verdaderamente la
preocupación de putin que la otan en la
unión europea se están aproximando más y
más a sus fronteras no olvidemos que en
el 2014
ucrania quería juntarse a la unión
europea y que el músculo prohibió lo que
desató una rebelión de lo de los
ucranianos y la caída del gobierno de
lukashenko
un aliado de putin
ahora ucrania se está aproximando más y
más a la otan es muy fácil porque tienen
fronteras con polonia por ejemplo puro
manía con otros miembros sea de la unión
europea que de la alianza militar y
naturalmente putin tiene el sueño de
reconstituir el imperio ruso y para él
la próxima danza de la otan significa
que no será posible particularmente con
la conquista que adquiere mucho que
hacer de un gran yo misma
y finalmente un encuentro entre joe
biden y vladimir putin es una cita
diplomática que genera interés
internacional sería esa la solución al
conflicto
bueno depende naturalmente de cómo se
desarrolla el encuentro y hay
naturalmente
aspectos positivos y negativos por
ejemplo ahora se está hablando también
de putin que quiero un poco acusar a la
unión europea porque porque él quiere
que se ha construido un gaseoducto desde
rusia a la unión europea pero los
alemanes en particular y otros están
exigiendo la aplicación de normas
europeas a esta construcción y putin
claro no lo quiere y podría ser también
una manera de negociar con los europeos
y naturalmente con los americanos para
no invadir a ucrania si le dan por
ejemplo esta extensión de normas
europeas es sí
los eeuu a eliminar las sanciones
impuestas sobre muchos de los miembros
del gobierno digamos de la cúpula en
rusia